SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
WELL FOR AGES. BRADFORD COME BY
ADAM CHIANG SALLY DODD THEY'RE
AWESOME GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG. HILL.
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING MORE
LAW MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN. I'M BURKE. WHITE HOUSE
SKI WIENER WELL. SENATORS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WERE WE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR GALGIANI.
ISN'T A GREAT TO BE BACK BY
POPULAR DEMAND. AS WE BEGIN
TODAY I'VE TAKEN A FEW
LIBERTIES WITH THE FOLLOWING
POEM BY BRENDAN KELLY CALLS
BEGIN AGAIN. BEGAN AGAIN TO THE
SUMMONING BIRDS TO THE SIDE OF
THE LIGHTS AT THE WINDOW. BEGIN
TO THE ROAR OF MORNING TRAFFIC
ALL ALONG L. STREET. EVERY
BEGINNING IS A PROMISE BORN IN
LIGHTS AND DYING AND DARK.
DETERMINATION AND EXALTATION OF
SPRING TIME FLOWERING THE WAY
TO WORK. BEGAN TO THE PAGEANT
OF QUEUING CONSTITUENTS THE
ARROGANCE LONELINESS OF CROWS
DOWNTOWN. BRIDGES LINKING THE
PAST AND FUTURE. OLD FRIENDS
PASSING THOUGH WITH US STILL.
BEGIN TO THE LONELINESS THAT
CANNOT TO AND SINCE IT PERHAPS
IS WHAT MAKES US BEGIN. BEGIN
TO WONDER AS UNKNOWN FACES. AT
CRYING BIRDS IN THE SUDDEN RAIN.
THOUGH WE LIVE IN A WORLD THE
DREAMS OF ENDING. IT ALWAYS
SEEMS ABOUT TO GIVE IN.
SOMETHING THAT'S WILL NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE CONFUSE CONCLUSION
AND SAYS THAT'S REFER EVER
AGAIN. AND SO GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD BE WITH US THIS
YEAR AS WE DARE TO TRUST THAT
OUR WORK CAN BENEFIT THE LIVES
OF SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR STATES.
WE THANK YOU FOR OUR COURAGE
AND TO OUR DESIRE TO BEGIN
AGAIN A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OR. AND
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR- WE HAVE WELCOME
REMARKS WELCOME BACK REMARKS
FROM MADAME PRO TEM. WELL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE ALL OF YOU
AND CERTAINLY MY PLEASURE AND
IN A MOMENT I WILL INCLUDE-
RECOGNITION OF OUR REPUBLICAN
LEADER FROM BAKERSFIELD TO
MAYBE ADD TO SOME OPENING
COMMENTS. SO IT'S REALLY A
PLEASURE TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU
US BACK TO THE SECOND OF OUR
TWO YEAR SESSION AND I THINK AS
YOU REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE LAST
IN THIS CHAMBER WE HAD TO LEAVE
IN A BIT OF A HURRY- SO I
WANTED TO BEGIN THEN MY
COMMENTS BY THINKING OF COURSE.
SOME IMPORTANT PEOPLE THE
CLEANING CREWS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
STAFF WHO GOT THE CHAMBER READY
FOR OUR RETURN AND IT TOOK A
LITTLE MORE EFFORT THAN YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE TO DO THAT JUST
TO BE CLEAR- AND CERTAINLY D.
G. S. WHO TAKES VERY GOOD CARE
OF US ALL YEAR ROUND. YOU KNOW
IT SEEMS LIKE A GOOD TIME TO
THANK AGAIN OF COURSE ARE
SERGEANTS AND THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS WHO
DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO KEEPING
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL SAFE
AND CERTAINLY DID THAT. FOR US
THE LAST NIGHT OF SESSION. I
HOPE YOU WERE ALL ABLE TO ENJOY
OF COURSE THE HOLIDAYS WITH
YOUR LOVED ONES TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT INTO THE COMMUNITIES
AND- GET SOME ENERGY AND IDEAS
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE
ORGANIZATIONS IN YOUR DISTRICTS
I KNOW THAT IDEA. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. THAT THE ENERGY
THAT DRIVES US AND BRINGS US
BACK HERE TODAY- THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE OF
MY DISTRICT SHARED WITH ME AND
I KNOW YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY IT
IS GOING TO BE- NOT SHOCKINGLY
ARE SURPRISINGLY A VERY BUSY
YEAR. WE HAVE THE IMMEDIATE
TASK OF ADDRESSING THE BILLS
THAT WERE MADE TO YOUR BILLS
AND TWENTY NINETEEN SO WE HAVE
WORK TO DO IN JANUARY. WE HAVE
AN ONGOING RESPONSIBILITY TO
FIX OUR STATES CRISIS OF COURSE
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE HAVE TO KEEP
ADDRESSING THE INCREASING RISK
TO LIVES AND PROPERTY DUE TO
WILD FIRES AND CLIMATE CHANGE
AND I WANT TO THANK ANA. SENATE
HUESO- IN ALL OF THE MEMBERS
AND SENATORS WHO TOOK PART. IN
THE ENERGY AND THE UTILITIES
COMMUNICATIONS HEARING ON WILD
FAR RESPONSES IN NOVEMBER I
WANT TO THANK YOU THERE WERE
MEMBERS WHO CAME WHO WERE NOT
PART OF THAT COMMITTEE. SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT WORK
DURING THE INTERIM. AND MAKING
THE TRIP TO SACRAMENTO FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DID. IT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TO
INVESTIGATE AND REVIEW THE
OPTIONS. I TO ADDRESS
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR CURRENT
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUTTLE
PROCESS WE KNOW THAT. AND I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL TO ALL THE
LOCAL EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE OO AS I
LOOK AROUND THE ROOM AND I SEE
THE FOLKS WHO LIVED IT. EVERY
DAY- IN CALIFORNIA. I TO THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
OTHER IMPACTED PARTIES WHO
PARTICIPATED AND PROVIDED
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO ALL OF
US IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND TO
THOSE OF US WHO REACHED OUT
WHEN OUR COMMUNITY WASN'T. BY
IT IN DESPERATION TO- IN LYNN
MORAL SUPPORT- TO OUR
COLLEAGUES INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THE SENATE AS MOST
OF YOU KNOW A WHOLE THE NEXT
HEARING ON WILD FAR
PREPAREDNESS THIS WEEK THIS
WEEK THANK YOU FOR SCHEDULING
THAT SO QUICKLY. THE TOPIC WILL
BE TELECOMMUNICATIONS ISSUES
SURROUNDING WILDFIRE SO WE-
WILL CONTINUE WITH THAT WORK.
YOU KNOW OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL I
KNOW THAT TWENTY TWENTY IS
GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT YEAR
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WITH
THE CENSUS. THAT'S WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE CERTAINLY WITH
THE MARCH TO NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS- WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
OUR EFFORTS AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY. TO HELP ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE COUNTS AND EVERYONE
VOTE. REGARDLESS OF AFFILIATION
REGARDLESS OF STATUS- IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND WE DO OUR PART. TO SUPPORT
ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS FROM
WHEREVER WE CAUGHT. I WANT TO
TAKE A MINUTE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO THE STAFF TODAY- ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUES. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I'D PERSONALLY. AND
THE SENATE AS AN INSTITUTION
REMAIN COMMITTED TO CHANGING
THE CULTURE OF THIS CAPITAL.
AND PROVIDING A WORKPLACE THAT
VALUES RESPECT CIVILITY AND
DIVERSITY. ON BOTH HOUSES OF
THE LEGISLATURE WORK TO CREATE
THE WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT IT
WAS TO ENSURE A THOROUGH AN
INDEPENDENT PROCESS FOR
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
MISCONDUCT. AND I KNOW IT'S
BEEN AWHILE SINCE WE STARTED
THIS PROCESS BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
STILL COMMITTED WE ARE STILL
ENGAGED WE'RE STILL IN THAT
PROCESS AND I KNOW THAT YOU CAN
TAKE A WHILE TO BUILD TRUST.
BUT IF ANY STAFF OR MEMBER OF
OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY NEEDS THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT I
SINCERELY HOPE YOU WILL CALL ON
THEM. CHANGE DOESN'T COME EASY
BUT I KNOW CHANGE IS HAPPENING
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
AND I WANT TO PARTICULARLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE ARE VICE
CHAIRMAN FROM SANTA CLARITA
MEMBERS FROM CARMEL RIVERSIDE
AND LAGUNA MIGUEL. BECAUSE THIS
LAST YEAR AND A HALF FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE SERVED ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE. HAS BEEN A REAL-
EFFORT. I IN THOUGHTFULNESS IN
IN HOW WE APPROACH THIS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR THAT WORK I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FINALLY TO OUR
SECRETARY COUNTRY AREAS- THE
CHIEF ASSISTANT SECRETARY
MCNULTY AND ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE DESK STAFF I. FIRST
YOU LOOK RESTED. YOU ON BEHALF
OF US WE APOLOGIZE TO YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR ALL THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO DO THAT WE KNOW- WILL
CAUSE YOU MORE WORK BUT WE KNOW
THAT YOU'RE COMMITTED AND WE
KNOW THAT'S WHY YOU'RE HERE BUT
WE DO WANT TO THANK YOU. AND
WITH THAT I WOULD. VERY MUCH
WITH YOUR PERMISSION MADAM
PRESIDENT. LIKE TO OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER FROM BAKERSFIELD. TO A-
GIVE A WELCOME AND SOME
REMARKS. WELL THANK YOU AND
MADAME PRO TEM I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH IT IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME ALL OF
US BACK TO THE SENATE. FOR THIS
NEW TWENTY TWENTY NEW DECADE
NEW NEW CYCLE THAT WE HAVE.
IT'S THE SECOND YEAR AND I KNOW
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK THAT HAS
TO BE DONE. I WANT TO ECHO
WITH- THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM'S
COMMENTS REGARDING. THE DESK
STAFF AND HOW WONDERFUL THAT
YOU ABSOLUTELY ARE IN THE
LEADERSHIP AND- BERNIE. MISS
MCNULTY AND ALSO MISS CONTRAIRE
US. I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR THE HARD WORK THAT THEY PUT
IN LAST YEAR I KNOW. I HAVE
THERE WAS A LOT OF COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE AT THE END OF
LAST CYCLE THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONFUSION IN SOME STUFF THAT
HAPPENED. THAT I DON'T THINK
ANY BODY IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
INSTITUTIONHAS EVER
EXPERIENCED. AND SO- MOVING TO
THAT LITTLE ROOM AND YOU KNOW
THE HEARING ROOM AND THEN BUT
STILL FULFILLING OUR
OBLIGATIONS. AS LEGISLATORS AND
BEING ABLE TO SERVE AT THIS
SINCE OF CALIFORNIA. WANTING
THANK THE CAUCUS STAFF ON BOTH
SIDES- THEY WORK REALLY HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO. TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS. I DON'T
THINK ON MY MEMBERS WHO. WITH
US. LAST NIGHT. AND NOW WE
DISENGAGE IN A PROCESS WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TO ENGAGE IN BUT WE
ALL. THREE I DO DEFINITELY
THINK SECURE STAFF AND THAT THE-
IN ARMS A- REALLY GOOD CARE OF
US. AND MAKE WE'RE SAFE. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO A WONDERFUL
TWENTY TWENTY N. M. THAT
EVERYTHING WORKS OUT. MUCH
BETTER THAN IT DID LAST YEAR.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON THE HOMELESS ISSUES WE HAVE
THIRTIES THAT WE SET THE PLACE
AND I THINK THAT. WE AGREE ON A
LOT OF THOSE THINGS YOU KNOW
THE HOME THAT SHE WAS ONE OF
THE NUMBER ONE CRISIS IS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
WATER ISSUES AND INTRA VALLEY
WHERE WE GREW UP THE SUIT YOUR
CONSTITUENCY. THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS YEAR TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA. MORE AFFORDABLE AND
A PLACE TO LIVE IN A SAFER
PLACE TO LIVE. SO I'M THINK
VERY MUCH THE OPPORTUNITY JUST.
A FEW MARKS AND NOW LET'S NOT
TO ALL. AS WITH THEIR WORK IN
TWENTY TWENTY- MOVING ON IN THE
AGENDA. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RECORD RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOR AMENDMENTS WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. SB. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE AND SB THREE SB
THIRTY EIGHT. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING A BILLS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY THREE. BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS
IS THE TIME TO ADDRESS THE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY MOTIONS
FROM SENATORS SENATOR BATES AND
SENATOR MORLOCK. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM- I
HAVE AN INJURED IN MEMORY FOR
AN ICON OF ORANGE COUNTY MANY
OF YOU MIGHT HAVE ALREADY- SEEN
HER OBITUARY BUT I'D LIKE TO
READ PORTIONS OF IT BECAUSE
JOAN IRVINE SMITH WAS CERTAINLY
A WOMAN FOR ON THE CENTURY I'M
NOT JUST THE DECADE HER LIFE
AND FOR ACCOMPLISHMENTS SAW
LAWS CERTAINLY ARE SPAN THAT
MANY MANY DECADES TO LET ME
BEGIN- JOAN IRVINE SMITH OF
PHILANTHROPIST ARTS PATRON AN
HEIRESS TO ONE OF ORANGE
COUNTY'S FOUNDING FORTUNES. WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING UC
IRVINE DIED THURSDAY HER FAMILY
SAID SHE WAS EIGHTY SIX SHE WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
IS ATHLETE I NEED TO IRVINE AND
RAISED IN BEVERLY HILLS
PASADENA IN WHAT WAS THEN RURAL
ORANGE COUNTY HER FATHER DIED
OF TUBERCULOSIS WHEN SHE WAS
TWO AND BY AGE FOUR SHE WAS
CALLING HERSELF JOAN INSPIRED
BY THE CHARACTER OF LITTLE
JUMPING JOHN. IN A MOTHER GOOSE
NURSERY RHYME THE FAMILY
BUSINESS THE IRVINE COMPANY WAS
FOUNDED BY HER GRANDFATHER
JAMES IRVINE THE SECOND IN THE
FAMILY RANCH ORIGINALLY COVERED
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND ACRES OR NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF ORANGE COUNTY ON HIS
DEATH IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN
SHE INHERITED A MINORITY SHARE
OF THE COMPANY WHICH HE HAD
pPROFIT PHILANTHROPIC FOUNDATION
THE JAMES IRVINE FOUNDATION.
WHOSE BOARD IT SHE WOULD BATTLE
FOR YEARS AND CERTAINLY THAT
WAS SO CHRONICLED IN THE PAPERS
OVER MANY MANY YEARS IN FACT
THE DECADE SHE WAS TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHEN SHE JOINED THE
IRVINE COMPANY'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS REPLACING HER MOTHER
AS THE ONLY FEMALE MEMBER SOUTH
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN LADIES
IT WAS THEN THAT I BEGAN MY
VERY LIBERAL EDUCATION IN THE
MAC THE NATION'S OF CORPORATE
INTRIGUE SHE SAID YEARS LATER.
HE QUICKLY ESTABLISHED HERSELF
AS AN INDEPENDENT MINDED BOARD
MEMBER INTO OTHER MEMBERS A
FREQUENTLY VEXING DISSENTING
VOICE. IT. THEN CHAIRMAN CALLED
HER SPOILED IN GUIDED BY SELF
INTEREST IN WHAT I WOULDN'T
UNDERSTAND ME WENT OVER
STATEMENT. JOHN IRVINE SMITH
WAS GUIDED BY AN INTEREST THAT
CERTAINLY BENEFITED GENERATIONS
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND SOME
CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. SMITH FOUGHT THE
BOARD TO PREVENT WHAT SHE
CALLED THE RAPID AND DISORDERLY
DEVELOPMENT OF THE RANCH LANDS
AND WAS SAID TO CARRY A HIDDEN
TAPE RECORDER TO BOARD
MEETINGS. SO DEEPLY SHE
DISTRUSTED THE OTHER MEMBERS.
AFTER YEARS OF LOBBYING SHE AND
HER LAWYERS PERSUADED CONGRESS
TO CHANGE THE TAX CODE. TO CURB
STAFF TAX EXEMPT FOUNDATIONS
FROM RUNNING PRIVATE FIRMS
WHICH HELPED HER TO FINALLY.
DISLODGE THE FOUNDATION FROM
DOMINANCE OVER THE COMPANY. SHE
WAGED A CAMPAIGN WHICH SHE
DESCRIBED AS A FREQUENTLY
BETTER TWO YEAR BATTLE TO FORCE
THE IRVINE COMPANY BOARD TO
DONATE ONE THOUSAND ACRES OF
LAND IN NINETEEN SIXTY. FOUR
THE CAMPUS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE HE TOUTED IT
AS GOOD BUSINESS DECISION
POINTING TO THE ECONOMIC AFFECT
UCLA HAD HAD IN LOS ANGELES.
SOMETIMES DESCRIBED AS REGAL
THE ECCENTRIC IRASCIBLE SHE
PORTRAYED HERSELF AS THE
GUARDIAN OF THE IRVINE COMPANY
FOUNDED BY HER GRANDFATHER. IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTY SHE
FEUDED PUBLICLY WITH DONALD
BROWN WHO HAD BECOME THE IRVINE
COMPANIES MAJOR SHAREHOLDER AND
FOUGHT UNSUCCESSFULLY IN COURT
TO BLOCK HIS PROPOSAL TO MERGE
THE FIRM WITH HIS HOLDING
COMPANY. SHE SAID THE MERGER
WAS UNFAIR TO MINORITY
SHAREHOLDERS LIKE HERSELF AND
WOULD SETTLE THE COMPANY WITH
HEAVY DOWN ON THAT SHE HAPPENS
NOT BE QUITE RIGHT GUYS. SHE
FINALLY SEVERED TIES WITH THE
COMPANY IN NINETEEN NINETY WHEN
SHE AND HER MOTHER TOOK A TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR BUYOUT. HE WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT PARTICIPANT IN THE
HISTORY OF ALL NEW CITY OF THE
ALL NEW CITY OF IRVINE IN
ORANGE COUNTY BROWN SAID SHE
WILL BE MISSED. HE CHAMPION
CRYSTAL COVE STATE PARK AND
PART OF WHAT HAD BEEN HER
FAMILY RANCH AND FOUNDED THE
IRVINE MUSEUM WHICH SHE FILLED
WITH HER ART COLLECTION NOTABLY
IN THE JOHN RAY OF CALIFORNIA
IMPRESSIONISM. OBSERVERS
SOMETIMES SPECULATED THAT SHE
WAS TRYING TO ATONE. FOR HER
FAMILY'S ROLE IN PAVING OVER A
GOOD PORTION OF THE COUNTY. IN
TWO THOUSAND WHEN SHE STOOD UP
TO OPPOSE A DEVELOPER'S PLAN TO
PUT NEW COTTAGES. AT CRYSTAL
COAST STATE PARK THE CROWD
CHANTED HER NAME THE PLAN WAS
DEFEATED AND AS YOU KNOW THAT
IS A BEAUTIFUL COASTAL SHARK-
AS IT SITS TODAY. SMITH WAS
ALSO SMITH ALSO PLAYED A ROLE
IN ESTABLISHING THE LAGUNA
COAST WILDERNESS PARK. IRVINE
PARK IN THE IRVINE BOWL SHE
WANTED TO CARRY THE MANTLE. SEE
SAID ELLEN BELL A BOARD MEMBER
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY HISTORICAL
SOCIETY AND HIS HISTORIAN OF
THE AREA. SHE WAS PART OF THE
MOVEMENT THAT MADE THE CITY OF
IRVINE OF TODAY POSSIBLE. SHE
IS SURVIVED BY HER THREE SONS
JAMES IRVINE SWINDON RUSSELL S.
PENNIMAN THE FOURTH AND MORTON
IRVINE SMITH AND SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE THE HONOR IN ART THE
ENTERTAINMENT ACTUALLY TO HAVE
THE WORKS WITH A JOHN ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES WHEN I WAS ON
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND SHE CERTAINLY
WAS EVERYTHING THAT SAYS IN
THIS MENTAL OR MEMORIAL ABOUT
HER ONE HECK OF A WOMAN- SHE
REALLY ON A CARD THE FUTURE FOR
IRVINE AND CERTAINLY FOR WOMEN
ON THEIR PLACE ON BOARDS AND
WHAT THEY BRING TO YOU- THE
MANTLE OF LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU.
SENATOR MOORLACH THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT HAPPY NEW YEAR.
JOAN IRVINE SMITH WAS AN
INCREDIBLE ART COLLECTOR SHE
PURCHASED SOME OF THE MOST
AMAZING CALIFORNIA OPPRESSION
IS START WORK. IT WILL BE ON
THE PLANET SHE'S PROBABLY.
ACQUIRED SO MUCH THAT'S
INCREASE THE VALUE OF ALL THE
REMAINING PIECES OUT THERE BUT
IF YOU WANNA SEE WILLIAM WENT
TO OR EDGAR PAINTER JACK
WILKINSON SMITH- PLEASE COME TO
MY OFFICE THERE ON DISPLAY-
THERE ON LOAN FROM THE URBAN
MUSEUM WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLE.
OPPORTUNITY WHEN YOU EVER COME
TO ORANGE COUNTY NEAR THE JOHN
WAYNE AIRPORT AND SHE IS
DONATED- COLLECTION- TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
SO WE ARE ALL BENEFICIARIES-
FROM HER- GENEROUSLY GENEROSITY
SO I HAD THEM UP IN MY CAPITOL
OFFICE HAD THEM UP OF MY
SUPERVISOR'S OFFICE. IN FACT
WHEN ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER WAS
GOVERNOR HE ACTUALLY HAD
ORIGINAL PIECES FROM HER
COLLECTION IN THE LOBBY. IN YOU
CAN STILL SEE SOME OF THEM
THERE- ON DISPLAY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RIGHT
HERE ON THE FIRST FLOOR- THAT
ARE AVAILABLE BUT WE HAVE A LOT
OF FUN. SENATOR BATES TONIGHT
WORKING WITH JOAN IRVINE SMITH
WE HAVE SENT IN FREE. NUCLEAR
GENERATING PLANTS- JUST AT THE
NORTH PART OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SOUTH PART OF. ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE ONLY ROAD IN AND OUT
WAS THE HIGHWAY FIVE AND WE
JUST. SAID WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
WAY. TO FIND AN ALTERNATE ROUTE
GOT YOU KNOW TO GET OUT OF IF
ANYTHING EVER HAPPENS. AND SO
WE HAVE THE POTTER ROAD. OR
AVENUE TO THE POTTY ALL THE FUN
STUFF WE DO WITH SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO AND THANK WITH MANY.
BUT BUT WE HAD THE LANDFILL IN
BETWEEN BUT- CENTER BATES AND I
WORK REALLY HARD WHEN WE HAD
OUR EIGHT YEARS ON THE BOARD
TO. CONNECT LOW PADA AND THAT
WAS. BASICALLY AN INSPIRATION
FROM JOAN IRVINE SMITH. TWO
INTERESTING STORIES THE FIRST
IS WHEN I FIRST BECAME A
SUPERVISOR. THE COUNTY HAD JUST
COMPLETED RECREATING THE IRVINE
RANCH HOME IT'S CALLED THE KT
WHEELER LIBRARIAN IRVINE IT IS
AN IDENTICAL. REPRODUCTION OF
pTHE ORIGINAL IRVINE RANCH HOME
THAT HAD BURNED TO THE GROUND.
AND JOAN IRVINE SMITH CALLS ME.
AND SAYS I JUST TOURED THE
PLACE IT WAS JUST BEFORE WE'RE
GOING TO DEDICATED AND SHE SAID
I FEEL LIKE A FOURTH GRADER ALL
OVER AGAIN IT'S ALL THE SAME
FROM WHEN I WAS A CHILD AND SHE
WAS SO ANIMATED IT WAS ONE OF A
REAL FUN PHONE CALL- TO HAVE-
ONE OF THE- AWKWARD PHONE CALLS.
WAS A REPORTER. AND HE CALLED
AND SAID I SEE YOU HAVE ALL
THIS ARTWORK FROM THE IRVINE
MUSEUM IN YOUR OFFICE HOW ARE
YOU REPORTING THAT. ON YOUR
CONTRIBUTION FORMS THAT I SAID.
I SAID THERE ON LOAN. THIS IS
THIS SHOULD BE MORAL ACT
DECORATES OFFICE FOR FREE.
ARTICLE BUT NO HE SAID TO. NOW
THIS IS AN RIGHT WHAT IF THEY
LOAN YOU A CAR. AND I SAID WELL
HOW LIKE HOW WOULD I GET THAT
CAR UP TO THE FIFTH FLOOR. OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
SHOW IT OFF TO EVERYONE
BECAUSE- JONAH RYAN SMITH
WANTED HER ARTWORK OUT IN
PUBLIC. AND I SAID HEY EVEN THE
GOVERNOR HAS HER ARTWORK. HE
CALLED THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND DEMANDS TO KNOW HOW ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER'S GOING TO
REPORT THE VALUE OF THE
PAINTINGS. IN THE LOBBY ON HIS
ANNUAL OR HIS IS HIS REPORTS OF
AN END IT. REPORTER CALLS ME A
DAY AFTER THE ARTICLE CAME OUT
TO THE WASN'T A VERY NICE
ARTICLE. AND HE CALLS ME SAYS
YOU KNOW I JUST GOT OFF THE
PHONE WITH JOAN IRVINE SMITH IT
WITH A THREE HOUR PHONE CALL.
BUT ONE OF THE SAD PARTS ABOUT
THAT ARTICLE IS THAT. THE
CHANCE TO JUMP BUT BUMP INTO OR
HER SON JAMES IRVINE SWINDON
AND HE SAID YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET SO MANY MUSEUMS
TO GET THEIR PIECES OUT IN
PUBLIC. WHEN THAT ARTICLE HIT.
A LOT OF THE MUSEUM SAID WE
DON'T WANT TO GO THERE NOW. AND
SO THAT REPORTER DESERVED A
THREE HOUR PHONE CALL FROM JOAN
IRVINE SMITH BUT SHE WAS AN
INCREDIBLE. THE MATRIARCH IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND IT IS AN
HONOR TO ADJOURNMENT ROOM
MEMORY AND- WHICH THE FAMILY.
OUR DEEPEST REGARDS AT THIS
TIME OF LOSS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE EXTEND OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AS WE.
MEMORIALIZE HER HERE TODAY
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I TOO WANT
TO WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY NEW
YEAR IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I STAND HERE- AND A GREAT
SENSE OF LOSS THAT IASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF A
DISTINGUISHED CALIFORNIAN AND
THAT IN THE PERSON OF DEREK DR
DEREK MARSHALL BETTER KNOWN AS
DAIRY. A INDIVIDUAL THAT- HAS
BEEN A FRIEND OF MINE FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS THOUGH HE
RESIDES IN SENATOR MITCHELL'S
DISTRICT DOCTOR MAC MARSHALL
WAS BORN IN AUGUST TWENTY
SECOND ON AUGUST TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE IN
WASHINGTON DC THE YOUNGEST OF
THREE CHILDREN TO THE DOCK TO
HIS PARENTS DR GRANT BILL H.
MARSHALL SENIOR. AND JACQUELINE
S. MARSHALL AND HE'S THE NEPHEW
OF THE RENOWNED SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE THURGOOD MARSHALL THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN EVER BE
APPOINTED TO THE COURT DOCTOR
MARSHALL IN HIS FAMILY MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN SIXTY
WORRY ATTENDED WINDSOR HILLS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
WESTCHESTER HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS
AN EXCEPTIONAL ATHLETE HE LOVE
PARTICIPATING IN SPORTS
ESPECIALLY POP WARNER YOUTH
FOOTBALL. DOCTOR MARSHALL
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
FRANCISCOWHERE HE PARTICIPATED
IN AN EMERALD GENERAL SPORTS
AND WAS ACTIVE IN SEVERAL CLUBS
AND ORGANIZATIONS DEVELOPING A
KEEN INTEREST. IN CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AND SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT.
PERFECT FILL HIS CHILDHOOD GOAL
OF BECOMING A DENTIST. DOCTOR
MARSHALL WORK DILIGENTLY TO
COMPLETE HIS COURSE WORK IN
JUST THREE YEARS IN A ROW IN
HOWARD UNIVERSITY WHERE HE
GRADUATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. UPON GRADUATION HE JOINED
HIS FATHER TO FORM THE MARSHALL
DENNIS GROUP PRACTICE CERTAIN
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT LOS SANDERS AND ONE
OF THE MOST RESPECTED. DENNIS
ORGANIZED DENTISTRY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE AREA I
HAVEN'T MET THE LOVE OF HIS
LIFE AFTER RETURNING HOME FROM
COLLEGE DR MARCIA MERRY COLLEEN
NEIL ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY SIX.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE COUPLE
RAISE TWO CHILDREN TWINS
DANIELLE WHO FOLLOWED HER
FATHER FOOTSTEPS TO ATTEND
HOWARD UNIVERSITY. AND DEREK
WHO'S IN ROAD NOW IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEW MEXICO HIS
WORK EXTENDED INTO THE
COMMUNITY WHERE HE SERVED AS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER ON THE ANGEL CITY
DENTAL SOCIETY. THE NATIONAL
DENTAL ASSOCIATION AND HOWARD
UNIVERSITY ALUMNI CLUB OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. HE ALSO WAS A
MEMBER OF CHAI DELTA MU
FRATERNITY AND SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AS THE HOME
AND ON THE HOME IN UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH WILL NOTICE
AFTER AMERICAN CHURCHES IN LOS
ANGELES ALSO IN THIS PAST TIME
ENJOYED ROOTING FOR THE LAKERS.
THE DODGERS AND THE RAIDERS ANY
ENJOY LIVE MUSIC I USE IT TAKE
GREAT DELIGHT AND SEEN HIM OUT
TO ANNUAL PLAYBOY JAZZ FESTIVAL
WORK HE WOULD HOLD COURT IN A
BOX WITH MANY OF HIS MINISTRY
COLLEAGUES. DOCTOR MARSHALL
LEAVES TO MOURN HIS PASSING HIS
WIFE CALLING. HIS JORDAN DEREK
SPENCER MARKS TO JUNIOR HIS
DAUGHTER DANIELLE LISBON
MARSHALL IS SIBLINGS AND MANY
MORE FAMILY AND FRIENDS ONE
BEING. SAMUEL JOSEPH HILL HIS
CHILDHOOD FRIEND AND FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE MEMBERS I HUMBLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN INTO MEMORY
OF DIRT MARSHALL DR JERK
MARSHALL WHO WAS ADMIRED AND
APPRECIATED FOR ITS GENEROSITY
OF SPIRIT. IS LOVE OF FAMILY
AND IS WONDERFUL SENSE OF HUMOR
AND A GENUINE CAPACITY TO HEAR
HIS TIME AND TALENTS WITH ALL
THAT HE- ENCOUNTERED HE WAS
EXCEPTIONAL DENNIS BUT YOU MORE
IMPORTANTLY WAS EXCEPTIONAL.
HUMAN BEING I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN. IN HIS MEMORY HE WILL
BE SORELY MISSED BUT NEVER
FORGOTTEN. PLEASE BRING DOCTOR
MARSHALL'S. NAME TO THE DESK SO
THAT HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- WE WILL RECONVENE
ON THURSDAY JANUARY NINTH AT
NINE AM THANK YOU. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT WHAT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT NINE AM